il est donc essentiel d'apporter la
sécurité juridique nécessaire pour
informer et valoriser les vignobles de
france
l'autorité war et le paysage quand on
parle de 20 ans parle pas d'alcool il a
quand même un point qui est un peu
difficile à entendre vous plaît venez
mai s'attendre
souvenez vous en 2015 le sénat a
assoupli la loi evin en adoptant un
amendement polémique
son but ouvrir la porte à la publicité
indirecte pour l'alcool dans les médias
les opposants dénoncent un coup de force
du lobby du vin un an plus tard lors
d'un colloque au sénat de l'association
des élus de la ville on se réjouit des
facilités que cet amendement à porte
pour défendre les intérêts du monde
viticole
le marché du tourisme à l'importance
économique et culturel parce que c'est
très bien on dit des lobbys qu'ils sont
omniprésents puissants et qu'ils
arrivent même à faire changer les lois
bien sûr je suis d'accord pour dire que
la belgique puisque c'est la réalité
pour la vivre presque au quotidien
le lobby n'est pas un gros mot à
condition de ne pas utiliser laisser
utiliser ce terme de manière
nécessairement péjoratif
ce qui serait malsain on le voit très
bien ce serait qu'il y ait des
influences souterraines qui sont ils
vraiment comment travaille-t-il nous
allons tenter de vous faire découvrir
comment les groupes d'intérêts influence
le travail législatif
rue de varenne à paris à deux pas de
l'hôtel matignon en plein coeur du
quartier des ministères
un cabinet de lobbying idéalement situé
oui on pèse dans le débat public dans le
débat politique et en influence et on se
bat pour ça et quant au parlement
n'arrive pas à ses influences et on se
bat dans les médias pour qu'on puisse
influencer les parlementaires et on a un
seul objectif c'est de gagner
lobbyiste depuis 30 ans
thierry costes oeuvre pour les intérêts
des chasseurs et il assume de vouloir
influencer les textes de loi sur son
bureau parmi ces documents de travail
figure la liste des élus présents en
séance
classés par département avec la position
de chacun on fait des tableaux avec qui
étaient là ont fait des tableaux plus
fin avec qui était présent et a voté
quoi notamment côté les scrutins publics
donc ça on trace soyez les gens qui
étaient là un jour 2 jours 3 jours en
fonction des enjeux qu'il y avait sur la
chasse parce que parce que les
parlementaires peuvent parfois avoir
envie de dire j'étais là il n'était pas
mais en fiche les gens donc non non on
fait des tableaux de synthèse c'est pour
nous c'est c'est le conducteur c'est
notre c'est notre fil conducteur quand
on bâtit une stratégie il faut pas se
perdre dans
dans la diffusion de toi tout le monde
parce que ça lasse tout le monde
les parlementaires reçoivent des
centaines de mails il a envoyé aux
parlementaires une version remaniée du
projet de loi biodiversité avec les
propositions d'amendement de la
fédération nationale de la chasse on
contacte les sénateurs qui seront
influents qui débattront du texte parce
qu'ils sont à la bonne commission la
commission environnement et qu'ensuite
ils seront en séance mais on convainc
aussi les chefs de groupe
les présidents de groupe on va parfois
même jusqu'à convaincre le président du
sénat on est très interactif
c'est à dire que on connaît bien les
parlementaires je les côtoie depuis
longtemps je les fréquente beaucoup pas
seulement situations d'urgence vous
pouvez va demander aux gens de vous
aider si vous ne les voyez qu à ce
moment là
et pour convaincre rien de mieux que le
contact direct le parlement pour un
lobbyiste est un lieu stratégique
thierry costes il passe pas mal de temps
ce jour là il a rendez vous au sénat
pour discuter chasse et biodiversité
à force de côtoyer des parlementaires
quand même on en a des relations de
confiance et de ses pratiques à ce
bureau il le connaît bien
c'est celui de françois patriat sénateur
ancien député et ancien ministre de
l'agriculture doit maintenant dire
bonjour vous deviendrez bonjour bonjour
nous étions nous étions inquiets
pourquoi tu étais du groupe à latence et
été séquestrés au groupe d'allonger
coûte les deux hommes sont proches
il leur arrive même de chasser ensemble
thierry costes est venu lui expliquer
pourquoi il faut retoqué les articles
anti chasse a levé ce jeu qui viens vous
parler par exemple de la chasse dans les
territoires ruraux en france je vous
entends leur a dit différemment de
conseiller technique
moi j'aime bien travailler avec des
lepénistes parce que je pense que les
conseillers en communication sont
souvent beaucoup moins pertinent dans la
perception des choses
albis c'est pas ce quelqu'un qui vient
faire pression sur vous
quelqu'un qui vous donne des éléments de
jugement entretenir un dialogue
permanent serait donc la clé pour être
persuasif
le jour du vote sur le texte
biodiversité
thierry costes est présent au sénat
salle des conférences en terrain connu
il retrouve le sénateur jean-noël
cardoux président du groupe d'étude sur
la chasse
s'il va bien comment tu vas me colle
vous êtes cinéma oui et c'est gênant si
tout filmé avec un cachet certain
horrible du lycée de la chaîne mais moi
je lis suis interne hier il ya une
montée au créneau de parlementaires de
gauche et de droite et des votes qui
sont qui sont pas politiques sont sauvés
la chasse en france un peu comme le
fromage prendre en compte les
territoires ruraux et ses enjeux un
argument de poids au sénat et ce n'est
pas le président du groupe chasse qui
dira le contraire
groupe d'étude le plus important avec
plus de 80 membres
n'a pas pesé en a contre pesé pourquoi
on a été d'être actif parce que l
assemblée nationale d des attaques très
virulente inattendus ont vu le jour
contre certaines formes de chasse et à
partir de là alors là le monde de la
chasse a été très très fortement
mobilisés et le groupe chasse du sénat
était le vecteur de cette mobilisation
et nous nous avons pu réussir à
supprimer ces cesser ces amendements ces
attaques
les sénateurs ont réussi à sauver la
chasse à la glu une technique ancestrale
pratiquée dans plusieurs départements en
france l'électorat chasse pêche
représente près de 3 millions de
personnes
vous savez ça fait 30 ans que qu'est-ce
que je suis car en tant que que
gravitent dans le monde de la chasse a
fait trente ans que je connais ce
monsieur où on s'est fréquenté la
plupart de ceux que j'ai retrouvé dans
nos milieux d'achat ce que j'étais
élu une présidence du gonflage déconner
ça depuis très longtemps une autre
connaissance de longue date c'est un
salut quand le rapporteur de la loi
biodiversité au sénat thierry costes le
connais bien il a été l'assistant
parlementaire de jérôme bignon quand il
était député
parce que sinon c'est politiquement
compte diffuser les abonnés seraient dus
ces plaisirs des cris et des z'arts
émotions mais sinon c'est long je pense
que politiquement si tu ne prends pas
situer reste pas sur cette ligne avec
moi la main jugement je suis ministre
demain à l'assemblée jeudi voyait déjà
qu'il était ma vision était presque est
exaucé la table et on disait presque
plaisir promis
les organisations professionnelles aussi
font du lobbying à la fnsea influencer
le contenu d'une loi est un travail de
tous les instants des propositions
d'amendements et des argumentaires sont
envoyés pour chaque article
ensuite le plus dur reste à faire
s'assurer que le message est bien passé
lorsque les débats ont lieu
eh bien on a des tableaux de suivi un
moment par amendement qui le portent qui
défend quoi est-ce que nous sommes
favorables ou pas favorables parce qu'il
a été adopté ou pas adopté ce qui nous
permet de faire permet de faire un suivi
au jour le jour
envoyer quand sévère n'y ait pas de
souci quand ces roses attention et quand
c'est rouge c'est un c'est un vrai sujet
lorsqu'un par l'amateur intervient et
que son argumentation nous paraît
suffisamment appropriée c'est
certainement parce qu'on n'a pas fourni
suffisamment d'éléments et bien on est
en contact avec lui soit directement
soit indirectement on est on est très
transparent
tant que c'est pas sifflé c'est pas
gagné mais tant que c'est pas sifflé
c'est pas perdu non plus donc jusqu'au
bout il faut travailler sur ces textes
là et pour influencer jusqu'à la
dernière minute un coup de fil peut
s'avérer efficace oui bonsoir c'est
christiane lambert chat vous appelle à
propos du passage de la loi pour la
dernière lecture à l'assemblée et un
amendement que auquel nous sommes très
attachés
donc je ne sais pas qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire passer comme message pour
essayer d'amadouer un peu ou d'atténuer
la portée de ces
élément là en tout cas c'est une demande
forte de la de la profession je suis à
votre disposition si vous voulez me
rappelais n'hésitez pas merci de votre
écoute au revoir nous sommes très
sollicités la pression se fait par le
rappel au téléphone par des courriers je
trouve que le plus ignoble et moi ce
même si c'était une bonne cote
j'hésiterais les soutenir dans des
conditions pareilles
c'est le petit paragraphe qui dit nous
sommes présents dans votre région
nous connaissons vos électeurs est votre
position sur ce sujet sera publié dans
les médias est un enjeu électoral et je
pense que si on limitait la reconduction
des mandats dans le temps les
parlementaires seraient plus
indépendants plus courageux puisqu'il ne
serait pas toujours en précarité en
campagne électorale pour leur futur
mandat il arrive même aux parlementaires
de recevoir des amendements prêts à
imprimer comme celui ci ne manque plus
qu'à rajouter le nom de l'élu la date
est le numéro d'un moment ça se
reconnaît dans l'hémicycle pendant les
débats quand vous vous apercevez que des
groupes qui sont apparemment
contradictoires politiquement dépose à
droite et à gauche
exactement le même amendement dans les
mêmes termes avec le même exposé des
motifs la immédiatement petits feux
rouges de vigilance c'est clair on sait
que c'est un lobby qui l'a écrit c'est
donc une réalité
les groupes de pression tente de mâcher
le travail des parlementaires et
fournissent du clé en main
ce féru d'informatique va nous le
montrer il a créé avec d'autres membres
du collectif regards citoyens un
algorithme de plagiat ont d'après les
documents de travail des lobbystes que
vous avez fourni et on l'a mis dans
notre moteur de recherche
à droite les amendements proposés par le
lobby de la chasse sur la loi
biodiversité à gauche ceux déposés par
les parlementaires résultats du copier
coller à la virgule près c'est un
amendement provenant du dessinateur
patriat dans lequel est bien on voit que
mot pour mot même si la la la
présentation est un peu différente
c'est exactement le même amendement ça
on le voit du sénateur patriat du
sénateur hervé qui est un sénateur
centriste et du sénateur navarro qui a
un sénateur non-inscrit et là
strictement les trois amendements sont
sont identiques
ça a créé dit totalement la thèse que le
lobby de la chasse se repose sur des
parlementaires qui sont proches de lui
en tout cas qui relaie de manière assez
systématique ses opinions dans le débat
parlementaire et qui se déroulait trans
couvre qui sont des relais transcourants
absolument c'est ça qui est sans doute
ça qui fait la spécificité de 2
des lobbys très influent c'est d'être
capable de porter des dispositions aussi
bien à droite qu'à gauche
et du côté du lobby agricole même
verdict du logiciel des morceaux de
texte identique
c'est le sénateur la serre et sur une
disposition assez similaire on a le
sénateur bizet qui paraît y dépose des
dispositions qui sont quasiment
similaires à celles du lobby agricole de
la fnsea on a vraiment l'impression que
il travaille mal en main dans la main le
travail qu'on a fait émerger des
sénateurs qui travaillent avec des
lobbys qui sont beaucoup plage et donc
c'est la fnsea et les chasseurs là où le
collectif des ong sont plutôt des
sources d'inspiration que un copier
coller du total
sénateur depuis 20 ans jean bizet défend
les positions du monde agricole
j'assume être du côté de ceux qui ont un
argumentaire j'assume être du côté des
socioprofessionnels parce que ce sont
eux les créateurs de richesse il s'est
opposé à l'interdiction totale des
néonicotinoïdes prévue dans le projet de
loi biodiversité et reçu des centaines
de mails des mails des ong de citoyens
parfois des mails de menaces pour tenter
de le faire changer d'avis et cette
affiche et les celles ci on a tous reçu
sénateurs tueur d'abeilles
nous avons retrouvé les assassins voilà
voilà dans quelle société nous vivons
nous ne sommes plus dans un état de
droit ce débat mon avis et est à la fois
surréaliste extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'en fin de compte on à légiférer sous
le poids de l'émotion et de
l'intimidation qui a été orchestrée par
ces ong pendant de nombreuses années
élargir le cercle de l' expertise à la
société civile faire de tout citoyen des
décideurs en matière environnementale au
dessus de la représentation nationale
c'était leur chiffre tout simplement le
cerc de l'arbitraire on en est là à mon
avis il faudra revenir si vous voulez
quand on reviendra en responsabilité à
une architecture beaucoup plus
rationnelle pas question d'y mettre les
ong ou les associations
il y aurait donc selon le sénateur des
groupes de pression plus légitime que
d'autres
générations futures a été très active
lors des débats sur la loi biodiversité
l'association qui travaille sur les
dangers des pesticides a défendu
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes
dangereux pour les abeilles elles aussi
tentent d'influencer la loi et ne s'en
cache pas un même argumentaire a été
envoyée aux parlementaires de tous bords
c'est normal que les parlementaires
écoute les parties prenantes mais c'est
pas normal c'était un rapport de force
entre les ong l'industrie qui importe de
1 520 milles et on n'a pas une force de
frappe du tout de la même nature que les
intérêts industriels
on en n'est pas non plus aussi inclus
dans les rouages je pense en deçà au
lobby agricole sa fait sont tellement
partout que finalement les instants de
lobbying sont permanentes
les thèses nos demandes du syndicat
fnsea sont répétés tous les moments de
la journée dans les élus qui vont à
statuer après son enterrement soumis à
ce rouleau compresseur idéologique alors
que nous pour pouvoir toucher un député
faucon demande un rendez-vous où là on
l'a pas et nous on considère que c'est
normal qu'au sénat dans tous les lieux
d'expression démocratique et la décision
on est la possibilité d'avoir une
expression de toutes les parties
prenantes mais elle devrait être sur un
pied d'égalité
on sait très bien que malheureusement ce
n'est pas le cas
l'exercice d'un flux ans n'a pas lieu
qu'entre les murs du parlement non loin
de l'assemblée nationale la maison de la
chimie est désormais l'un des hauts
lieux de l'organisation de colloques
parlementaire une pratique de lobbying
moins connus mais qui se développe
depuis de nombreuses années des
rencontres sur un thème qui réunit
hommes politiques monde de l'entreprise
et de la société civile
vous avez vous êtes ses élus au premier
rang directement interpellé ces
colloques permettent aux lobbyistes de
tous rangs d'avoir un accès direct à
ceux qui votent les lois d'entretenir de
bonnes relations
c'est ce que confirme l'organisateur
n'est ici des parlementaires des
ministres des gens qui ont le pouvoir de
faire bouger les choses pour qu'ils se
disent bah tiens c'est pas mal on
pourrait peut-être faire quelque chose
c'est bien sûr alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lobbying c'est ce qui fait
très peur parce que ça porte à villa
mans toute la question est de savoir si
le lobbying c'est prendre quelque chose
qu'on nous donne le traduire sans
réfléchir et reprendre l'amendement ont
copié collé ou si c'est la question du
livre arbitres que nous avons
les habitués ont surnommés ces
rencontres l'antichambre du dépôt
d'amendements en commission c'est aussi
l'occasion d'échanger adresse et cartes
de visite
et puis parfois des jeunes et ça
continue autour d'une table voilà et je
pense que c'est très bien pour alimenter
la réflexion les milieux parlementaires
il serait déjà arrivé lors de telles
rencontres que les financeurs privés qui
paye le plus et le temps de parole le
plus long mais comment dans ces cas là
gardée des débats objectif
en pratique derrière ces colloques sont
présentes plusieurs agences de lobbying
la première d'entre elles est mnm
conseil dont les locaux sont situés
juste en face de la maison de la chimie
son dirigeant pascal talent on nous
confirme que l'organisation de ces
colloques coûte cher qu'il faut trouver
des financements un intervenant peut
débourser entre 8000 et 20000 euros pour
le public c'est gratuit en fait le
financement et l'intervention son panier
il ya des gens qui interviennent mais
qui ne financent pas les gens qui
financerait qu'ils n'interviennent pas
c'est c'est pas ne sais pas il n'y a pas
un lien entre les deux sur une matinée
vous avez 20 intervenants
les macaques 5 qui ont financé pas plus
oui mais sinon ce bienheureux ci avait
20 20 financeurs maman s'appelle carte
le cabinet organise plusieurs colloques
par mois dont la plupart sont à
l'initiative de parlementaires
généralement quand il ya une initiative
elle nous vient d'un élu c'est rare
qu'il y ait un binôme droite gauche qui
se soit fait naturellement par lui-même
donc nous on lui dit bon c'est bien mais
il faudrait aussi un autre de l'autre
corps et que vous fassiez ensemble parce
que
notre souhait n'est pas d'organiser des
initiatives partisane et d'autre part
nous notre charte est une charte qui dit
que toutes les organisations qu'on fait
doivent être plus réaliste autres
méthodes de lobbying très prisé celle
des clubs parlementaire apparu dans les
années 90 il en existe une quarantaine
la sénatrice marie noëlle lienemann
préside le club de l'accession à la
propriété
elle assure que l'expertisé apportée par
ces clubs est nécessaire pour bien
légiférer
à l'heure où de plus en plus de textes
sont examiné en procédure d'urgence
j'écoute les arguments des autres du
blocage cordes quand on fait des lois
qui sont tatillonne qui sont mal adaptés
au terrain parce qu'on a aussi beaucoup
à payer à ce que le les textes de lois
soient opérationnelles atteignent
l'objectif qu'on a voulu que le
parlement a voulu fixer club des amis du
cochon club chiens et société
observatoire de l'oeuf des intitulés à
première vue fantaisistes quelques uns
sont tellement spécialisées qu'il est
difficile de ne pas y voir derrière les
porte-voix d'intérêts privés les
rencontres organisées par les clubs sont
un lieu privilégié pour mettre en
relation parlementaire et groupes de
pression de manière légale certes mais
aussi très opaque jeunes gens
merci françois merci infiniment à
bientôt ce lobbyiste a créé 15 clubs de
sa propre initiative au revoir en valais
c'est lui qui demande aux élus de l'est
présidé avec le souci à chaque fois
qu'il y ait un élu de droite et un de
gauche il considère que sans nous
n'acceptons c'est trop président s'est
montré que le sujet qui est porté par le
club les intéressent et ils sont
totalement disponible pour écouter les
professionnels que l'on va mettre autour
d'une table davantage pour des
parlementaires des membres de nos clubs
se soient les sujets c'est de pouvoir
bénéficier de l'organisation de
rencontres de petit déjeuner le petit
déjeuner de déjeuner ou dîner au gré des
rendez-vous les groupes d'influencé
tentent de tourner la loi à leur
avantage
et là encore des propositions
d'amendements peuvent circuler ce du
lobby totalement décomplexée mais c'est
une lubie totalement transparent dans sa
structuration dans la façon dont on la
pensait et on l'a voulu et c'est pour ça
que des parlementaires ont taxé via
accepte d'y venir où on a accepté d co
présidence ccre en effet on peut pas
faire plus transparent que notre modèle
pourtant ces clubs qui n'ont aucune
existence officielle au parlement ne
sont soumis à aucun encadrement aucun
contrôle certains ont des budgets
importants jusqu'à 400 mille euros se
pose alors la question du financement
le club de la table française a par
exemple pour partenaires et financeurs
la fédération qui représente la
charcuterie et son industrie ainsi que
la fédération française des spiritueux
il est important que le club ne laisse
pas entendre qu'il s'agit d'une
émanation de l'institution publique la
transparence elle viendra de la
publicité qui est donné l'identité des
organisateurs quand on sait qu'ils
financent tel ou tel événement c'est
assez facile rendre compte de leurs
activités afin d'éviter tout conflit
d'intérêts
c'est la demande de la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
suite à une étude sur ces clubs
un travail de l'ombre encore tabou alors
que la pratique s'est professionnalisé
depuis les années 90 le nombre de
cabinets de lobbying morts a été
multiplié par cinq
c'est maintenant c'est est bonne non
seulement pour voir ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble notamment sur le maroc est sur
l'afrique sont atteints par la suite une
profession qui s'est améliorée une
époque tout le monde se déclarer lobbies
parce qu'il y avait trois copains de
politique donc tout le monde faisait du
lobby on s'est aperçu qu'il suffisait
pas d'avoir des amis car des deux res
c'était aussi un métier de du de droit
bonne connaissance la matière
législative c'est un métier de
communication c'est un métier économique
l'enjeu pour le lobbyiste c'est d'être
apporteur de solutions anticiper les
besoins de ses clients
là on a un véritable rôle c'est de nous
mêmes éduquer nos propres clients les
entreprises privées à faire de la
prévention
trop souvent on vient nous voir parce
que un amendement est passé et empêche
demain une industrie d'exister j'ai
presque envie dire c'est trop tard donc
le le bing c'est aussi d'être en
situation de prévention de regarder au
sein de 2 la veille là par contre
législatif quels sont les alertes une
question posée à l'assemblée nationale
ou au sénat est un travail permanent que
doit l'ensemble des lobbies de veille de
pro activité très en amont de
l'évolution législative pour dire et
lancé des alertes
attention alerte il ya un député qui
commence à gratouiller sur vos métiers
parmi ses clients figurent en majorité
des entreprises privées car les
lobbystes interviennent surtout pour les
groupes industriels et financiers 10%
seulement représentent les ong
dans certaines entreprises le lobbying
se fait en interne directement les
spécialistes de l' influence occupe dans
les organigrammes un poste stratégique
directeur des affaires publiques à
pernod ricard ce poste existe depuis
près de 20 ans et garantit un meilleur
retour sur investissement pour
l'entreprise bac
sur le bureau de laurent scheer les
contacts d'autres groupes d'intérêts
influent notamment la carte de visite de
vin et société
le lobby viticole pour être efficace il
faut aussi savoir ce que défendent les
autres dans le coeur n'est pas affilié
vin & société directement mais comment
pro millions en france
des problématiques sont tes productions
peuvent être similaires
on a des les échanges une partie du
métier c'est aussi d'aller voir quels
sont tous les gens intéressés de manière
à avoir des messages cohérents et
convergents une façon alors d'élargir
son influence et de peser davantage sur
le travail législatif
les lobbys sont partout et pourtant les
règlements pour les encadrer ce n'est
que depuis 2009 que le parlement demande
au lobby de s'enregistrer et de se
soumettre à un code de bonne conduite au
sénat s'inscrire sur le registre est
obligatoire pour obtenir un badge
d'accès mais il figure à peine 150
professionnels de l' influence
c'est peu car le registre n'est soumis à
aucun contrôle
la maison le président de l'association
sherpa a rendez-vous ce jour-là au sénat
pour défendre ses propositions sur
l'encadrement des lobbys du côté
transparence jeu parce que bon voilà
certainement qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire puis on s'éloigne de
l'intérêt général plus le lobby est
cachée de il utilise des chemins de
traverse - il va se précipiter parce que
enregistrés sur les registres qui avait
eu au moment du scandale des médiateurs
ou de vol d'un certain nombre de lois
s'il y avait eu elles agissent de
lobbying obligatoire universel pour
sexualité aussi comme on pourrait
s'attendre d'eux
de l'omi d'agir comme ils l'ont fait
pour essayer d'éteindre eu des
conséquences de ce scandale encadrer de
façon plus stricte les lobbys c'est une
des mesures phares de la loi sapin de
sur la transparence de la vie économique
la france a du retard en la matière pour
la première fois une loi introduit le
terme lobbying elles prévoient un
registre obligatoire des groupes d'
influence publiques et consultables sur
internet et pour la première fois le
registre intègre les membres du
gouvernement et les cabinets
ministériels parce que la loi va créer
c'est un premier registre un premier
rookie d'encadrement des échanges donc
un peu plus de transparence sur qui sont
les représentants d'intérêts quelles
sont leurs activités et quels sont les
budgets qu'ils y consacrent
après il ya la question de la
traçabilité de la décision publique la
transparence dont une entre ces échanges
c'est à dire quelles sont les positions
qui sont transmises les notes de
position les a
man etc qui sont transmises aux
décideurs publics et quels sont les
rendez-vous qui sont pris entre les
lobbys et des décideurs publics et là
dessus on n'a pas encore d'éléments qui
sont prévus dans le projet loire
la loi sapin de et bien un premier pas
mais sans un encadrement des échanges
entre ceux qui font la loi et les lobbys
le registre obligatoire seule permettra
t'il vraiment d'éviter des dérives
ah ah
oh
tout